following on from the last video about
The Descent comps this one will continue
with the clear a storyline around the
simulation program she's building the
NSA analyst which is quickly becoming
one of my favorites and will even have a
couple of potentially new stories
starting up like always there will be
references to other videos I've made on
these colums so if you haven't seen them
yet you can find them in the
[Music]
description
trig I need a favor anything for my
favorite Evil Genius I'm not evil just a
genius what do you expect from a
trapezoid God I love your sense of humor
what do you need need you to do a field
test on those new warhounds for nap
already did aside from the creepy biped
action they're working great I want you
to run the test again with Anna you know
na doesn't want the the AI she wants the
guidance system how does she expect the
warhounds guidance system to operate
independently without an AI fine but is
she hates it you can remove Anna right
she's not just going to slip in there
and corrupt or rewrite the code or
anything like that right of course not
she's just here to collect data she's
not a person trick she's not even a
shape just a series of ones and zeros
don't be paranoid it's not like she
could augment reality and murder The
Operators
carrying on with clear's attempt to upsp
and get as much as possible out of
Natalia's budget towards Cal's agent
training simulation program Maas is
asked by CLE to fi test the warhounds
again except this time using Anna she
and trig obviously get along well I
guess both of them being crazy smart
gives them a common ground to discuss
things that would go far over the head
of most people however CLA is a little
bit more manipulative Maas is
exceptionally loyal to Natalia and
expresses concern but CLA convinces them
that it's just for further testing and
that it won't impact anything Natalia is
after further to other coms we've
received regarding this CLA is
continuing to use Natalia's funding and
now Personnel to continue working on
assets that Natalia wants no part
of sir we need to abandon the site what
site the Detention Center what's
happening confirmed contamination what
kind of contamination Chimera not the
in New York affirmative how the
hell did he get here asymptomatic
carrier she was in New York before being
arrested at the mall one of the
protesters I knew we shouldn't have let
dcpd use a Detention Center no this was
one of ours ECOT terrorists was arrested
trying to light a Christmas tree on fire
we stopped that attack in New York
before all of this happened the same
group tried again in DC a week later
Isaac intercepted their comms at least
that's working we need more space we
need to quarantine the staff from the
detention center and move our operations
from the data center it's too risky to
stay here long term report to the
testing facility we'll set up a
quarantine I'll let the teams know give
me a day to get it all set up in the
meantime isolate and see if we can find
a way to Rapid test for infected we
don't need a rapid test since when Isaac
can detect viral loads well that's not
terrifying infected need to be separated
we don't know what the recovery rate is
infected doesn't mean dying and we can
study the asymptomatic carriers maybe
use their blood to find the vaccine we
could get ahead of this thing you're a
prologist now no but Amherst is the
college professor yeah the not a viable
threat he made this if we can get into
his apartment or office we might be able
to reverse engineer this he
created sorry sir I didn't mean to swear
I'm just very tired it's fine we all are
get everyone packed and ready and bring
whatever you need to the facility to
continue working on containing this
thing thank you
sir this is from after the dollar flu
outbreak and is referencing two of the
classified assignments NSA site B13 and
the Detention Center at the NSA site
agents uncovered Intel that spoke about
more early warnings around Gordon
Amherst but also an eot terrorist called
Erica Gonzalez Erica was part of a group
that planned to set fire to a Christmas
tree in a New York mall likely ael's
department store she was arrested and
taken to the Detention Center where she
would be questioned it wasn't long after
that Erica was found to be an
asymptomatic carrier but unfortunately
for the 500 plus others who have being
kept on this site as well as the staff
it was too late the NSA site appears to
be where these coms between Kelvin and
the analyst were being recorded but due
to safety concerns they abandoned the
site this is the first piece of Intel
from the NSA analyst Calvin mcmanor
storyline that happens after the
outbreak has occurred after so many
alerts and warnings being presented to
Cal on five separate occasions by my
count that were all completely dismissed
I'm sure on a certain level the analyst
is feeling a little bit Vindicated by
updating Cal with this news
okay Cal your boys are outfitted in a
latest tech this is a state-of-the-art
simulation using augmented reality to
provide your operators a realistic
combat experience without having to
leave the comfort and safety of the
facility and protecting your investment
from prying eyes you don't have to sell
me on the pitch I already agreed to the
test agents are you ready Alpha Ready
sir Bravo ready good to see you again
Alex Vivian okay let's get this test of
yours underway your objective is to
utilize the mobile shade server to
access Intel and utilize your shade Tech
to infiltrate the bunker copy that this
is going to be fun oh look you did use
my fire turret after all oh only for the
simulation they are not suitable for the
field Viv good to know it wasn't
completely wasted work and hey nice to
confirm you can actually follow design
directions nicely done
Alex Alexander orz runs Cal through the
simulation that clear has been building
for his agents he leaves out the Minor
Details of who has be paying for
everything but realistically I don't
think Cal would care as long as he has a
foot up on Natalia I'm sure he's happy
what's interesting here is that Vivian
Conley now a division agent is one of
the agents running the simulation after
recently being Let Go by Ortiz robotics
I'm sure this interaction was awkward as
hell but also that we're starting to
hear more about some of the shd tech
that OTS have developed over time on top
of this we hear from another agent who's
become a little more prominent over
recent months agent Johnson perhaps
we're going to hear a little more around
what he's been up to over these comps
and the leadup to present day I'm very
conflicted about Johnson I don't trust
the fact that he has suddenly appeared
but at the same time time he is a
figurehead for the division 2 if you
haven't read the extremist mullus Comics
I'll have a link in the right hand
corner now he plays out like a character
who should absolutely be trusted so
while I think we're potentially going to
have a runin with him I think he'll be a
part of it for the best of reasons and
could possibly lead us to once again
questioning whether we're the good
guys what did he say that farmers
wouldn't have a leather briefcase does
he want me to make it look like a
toolbox instead no just make the outside
metal and remove the Insignia have the
Phoenix on the loading screen huh those
are actually good notes I thought so too
might be easier to waterproof and
definitely will be easier to conceal
with other metal objects than making a
farmer seem like a lawyer I think we
could get him to sign off on production
if he could see it in Action a field
test to prove the usage exactly in the
simulation room or in the field
simulation a safe it's easier to control
the variables to get the desired outcome
set it up I'm not going to lie I kind of
feel like I'm missing something here I
hope it's not just because I'm up so
late writing this but what do farmers
and briefcases have to do with anything
are they talking about the mobile shd
server here but if that's the case what
does this have to do with farmers are
these planned to be distributed to
Farmers far outside the major centers as
a fail safe for if the main servers are
taken down I guess that would make sense
and would actually be pretty smart the
whole shd network being taken down
multiple times over the months seems
like a massive floor in the system it
seems just a little bit too obvious of a
weak point however if this had been
planned for and a bunch of mobile
servers had been scattered across the
countryside overlapping with each other
this would be exceptionally more
difficult to locate and shut
down what's the point of this mobile
medical support nanotechnology deployed
to do field triage exactly we equip the
warhound with one of these Deployable
medical support stations they drop the
station into a combat area and the
nanotech goes to work assessing the
status of your operators in the field
they can cauterize wounds administer
small doses of adrenaline or combat
cocktails deploy expanding foam to stem
bleeding and you've built the Nanobots
for this they are still theoretical but
the deployment mechanism is real we have
the ones that deliver the expanding foam
but they are onetime use and they can't
fly back to the fly trap and be picked
up by the warhound fly trap that's what
Alex has been calling the device that
houses the nanot attack clever thank you
this is promising let me know when the
traps are fully
operational this one doesn't actually
seem to feed into any of the story ARS
that are playing out in these descent
comps of course there could be others
that add to this but I think this one
might be a little bit different I
actually find these ones kind of
interesting in their own right because
they go into a little bit more detail
around how some of the tech works the
this reminds me of a video I made a
little while ago now titled shd Tech
fiction or reality in the video I talked
about drones and turrets but this talks
more around nanotechnology from a
theoretical standpoint that would
eventually become the foundation of a
lot of different shd Tech it actually
makes me want to go read up on
nanotechnology now God I'm a
nerd as of today this should bring me
completely up to date with The Descent
coms I've collected so far although
there may have been a new one dropped
today that I need to grab I think I'm 2
to 3 weeks behind so for those of you
who are collecting them every week I'll
get there eventually following this
video I will release a recording of
comms 1 to 20 with timestamps included
so for anyone who doesn't play descent
who wants an easy reference point to
listen to these you'll be able to find
them here I'll continue to upload them
in bundles as I collect them unless
something significant drops for me to
talk about I likely won't be discussing
any more of these until I've managed to
grab a few otherwise I hope you've
enjoyed this and found it interesting
and extremist Ms extremer REM
[Music]
[Applause]
media